holy Sh what's wrong with us we will
remove five sins because we've total
assholes for tackling this Moody
this is the most confusing way of
stacking actors names basically ever
Robert Roy Shaw Richard Scheider
Dreyfuss
Kim what tress myself will be inspires
tons of horror movies where a woman
skinny dips and guy for whatever reason
can't go into the water with her sharks
that play with her food I mean the shark
doesn't see him hungry so much as he
seems like a Price is Right contestant
playing blink up did this shark not like
eat her legs or anything yet did he just
give her a ride around the ocean for a
bit what kind of a dick shark is this I
know a lot of alcohol is involved but
since when does chasing a hot naked
chick cause sudden passing out also he
didn't hear that mystery in the backyard
in Amity Sayed there in the end not too
fast from the cash that's racist
fuck is going on here a duster to dish
scrubbers three weirdly small plastic
spoons and a couple of keys all hanging
from a co rack the I guess whenever a
young man has seen ocean violence you
stick him in a room with a deputy in a
glass of milk water the fuck is that
what else could have done that to that
girl Boca Bella well I think possibly
yes uh boating is Howard
Brody moved to Amity at least seven
months ago and this medical examiner has
been around god knows how long
but it feels like this is the first time
these two have ever been told the town's
life blood comes from summer tourism
they went about declaring this a shark
attack and the most naive way possible
as if there wouldn't be resistance and
cover-ups from the mayor and business
owners yes this mayor guy is actually
wearing a suit with a million tiny white
anchors on it
that's good costuming some bad hat hat
maybe unintentionally inspires Bryan
Singer director of movies like Superman
Returns and Jack the giant slayer and
nothing else hmm
all these tasty legs just dangling
around in the water for me to eat but I
shall go after the kid on the raft his
mom will be the most pissed
look no doubt there would be business
owners and politicians who would deny
the fact of a shark out in the water but
ignoring two deaths including one that
happened right in front of a hundred
people I mean Jesus this is stupidity
that only happens in movies and real
life I guess
damn sin for real life literal
fingernails on a chalkboard to get
attention as opposed to half a dozen
other better ways to get attention in a
crowd of roughly twenty four people also
I know nails across a chalkboard can be
annoying but there's no way this sound
pierced all the sound of the dumb people
arguing if there's no shark and there
totally is one also can we take a look
at the shot just before Quint starts
scratching the chalkboard
it doesn't appear he's drawn that crude
picture of a shark eating a child yet
and he doesn't seem to be anywhere in
the background Quint apparated hear or
use the flu network dude who definitely
used his right hand to scratch a chalk
covered chalkboard immediately uses the
same hand to shove food in his mouth
thereby assuring he's eating some amount
of choc Brody checks out every book that
an overeager prop master I mean library
would lend him and he didn't even check
out the book with the pictures of the
weird sacrifices like everyone else in
horror movies does he's not on the ocean
he is in a boat he's not gonna go in the
water um if this kid is as scared as you
say he is I highly doubt he'd get that
close to the water either flash
foreshadowing being amazing after all
these people come to the island to hunt
down the shark and the media frenzy that
occurs that people don't decide not to
go to Amity this summer no matter what
happens I mean publicity wise this town
is already for lots of stupid and drunk
people drive their inadequate boats in
the water looking for a man-eating shark
and somehow there are no deaths or
injuries I'm not sure if you can hear it
but some guy on one of these boats just
asked what eight thousand dollars
divided by four is but that guy is
definitely not qualified to be out here
not because it was terrible math skills
but because he waited until now to even
ask this dispatch of chum was made with
strawberries premature celebration
fellas let's be reasonable huh no one
wearing this soup shirt tie combination
should ever utter these words still my
boy is dead now honestly no idea how the
sheriff doesn't commit seppuku after
this kind of public indictment they
caught a shark not the shark not the
shark that killed Chrissie Watkins by
the way did Chrissy's family ever show
up to ask about her she was pretty young
and probably had a family right or was
she just one of those mystical fairies
that show up at parties beckoning drunk
guys to swim naked with them I didn't do
anything I'm the chief of police America
that's like I thought came up with a
Gulf Stream
from southern waters a Louisiana license
plate does not prove the shark came from
southern waters last time I checked
people of all sorts of states drive
their cars into other states well so if
this shark really did swallow this
license plate in southern waters and
then went north how did it not expel
this thing one way or the other during
the time it took to get to Amity I mean
yeah I get it this isn't the shark but
come on man of science some of these are
bad deductions Sally and ion if you look
at it from the water that makes a lot of
sense Hooper would be excellent at
cinemasins man-eating shark helpfully
leaves behind a tooth so Hooper can find
it and know for sure he's still out
there
bad or he's hoping Hooper will slip a
dollar under his pillow tonight come on
man you stare at the dead guy for five
seconds and then you react and drop all
your I mean it would've made sense if it
happened right here but you looked at it
for hours before dropping the evidence
well where is that tooth this guy
believes that two qualified people would
bother to tell him the shark still out
there with absolutely no motive to lie
about it and even if the mayor saw this
tooth would that even make a difference
and this guy still has anchors sewn into
his suit my god those proportions are
correct love to prove that when you get
your name into the National Geographic
yeah but he only gets his name in there
if he proves the shark is there not by
making up a story so he can kill a whole
town's tourism industry but those
beaches will be open for this weekend it
is now officially astounding that Brody
doesn't do more at this point like call
the Coast Guard or the national media
yeah he might be out of a job here in
Amity but does he really need this job
can't he find some other sleepy town to
Sheriff one thing I've always wondered
if these assholes somehow not heard
about the shark attacks one thing for
the town to fight over keeping the
beaches open but the real problem should
be that after one or two shark attacks
abso-fucking-lutely no one would be
coming to these beaches MTV one family
Braves the waters and everyone who is
scared before decides to go in without
trepidation Steven Spielberg directs his
ass off so much in this movie I nearly
missed the part where he throws
coca-cola in our faces nearly seriously
how did these kids not get shot even a
little bit and after 10 seconds of
contemplation these people finally
realize that these kids are not a shark
shark Luck's out with the hoax just
before we attack so that this will see
him like a hot girl who cried wolf
scenario the heroes son falls into the
shark water and all I can think about is
Mary Jane Watson I think that means the
sinner too is in order
you may not have heard it but someone's
yelling does anybody have a gun
amazingly this is America and no one
does what a flying baby aah
the days you could smoke in a hospital
wait a minute what am I saying
lest you kids the product placement or
even excessive product placement is a
new concept please consult del Monte
Gamble's and Heinz just threw around
these tanks and they're gonna blow up
that's some nice foreshadowing valu nice
foreshadowing this movie's a spectacular
when it comes to suspense I mean
virtually nothing of note happens in the
scene but the sin kind of refused to
poke me with a stick like it usually
does when it's time to write something
it's setting things up for later it's
masterfully done and it's why we love
the moon when it proves one thing mr.
Hooper prove that you wealthy college
place don't have the education enough to
admit when you're wrong
hey this movie you really hate smart
people Wow good thing this shark doesn't
show up much in the movie because it
looks fake I wonder if they meant to do
that we've got one bow on him so we stay
out here do we find him again yeah but
we could radio Liddy get a bigger boat
nobody cares what you have to say Brody
you're in a Spielberg film in a time
where odd transitions were oddly the
norm oddly I got that feet
you got that feet movie steals the scar
showing scene from chasing a me anymore
so I read the shooting star is genuine
and not a digital effect but then
Spielberg would start digitally adding
them and seemingly every movie after
this making this one less special so
shooting star unintentionally inspire
Spielberg to run the effect into the
ground with so few chances to actually
hit this shark when it surfaces why not
attach a second barrel to the harpoon
rope where he'll even three the shark is
plenty big enough to take them down so
what's with this one at a time Bowl
and why don't we suddenly have children
running through a prairie music playing
during this scene goddamnit Hooper drops
everything when he's down in the water
he had his 8 Mile moment earlier now
here's where he's supposed to lay down
the sick rhymes about Clarence's parents
having a real good marriage I mean damn
dude why are you sad about good thing
bullets cause things like this to
explode in movies yeah
Arizona moon keeps shining from the
desert sky above hey pop shush
huh he's here what catfish hunter by the
sandbar you know that Sam fish is older
than I am
this means something it's important what
am I supposed to do while you're gone
nothing absolutely nothing
stop bad y'all so stop bad Sonny like
this what happens when you a stranger in
the ass Larry you know a tan with
money's a little like the mule with a
spinning wheel him score after
Frankenstein and he's certainly getting
the Welcome he deserves just sit right
back then you hear a tale tale of a
butcher never do by fella